[Musique]
tu sais rien de cette série docu sur la
spiritualité à travers le monde
il faudra des ambiances genre de musique
locale
faire du bien ce voyage bah il tait que
tu es triste tu as tu avoir un gros
problème dans ta vie avant d'arriver ici
et j'ai même vu communiquer avec les
morts oui notre monde
parce que j'étais pouvoir des pouvoirs
magiques tour maintenant apprendre à
t'en servir si c'est parce que vous me
racontez fait flipper ces bonnes femmes
je perds mon mari c'est déjà assez dur
comme ça on n'a pas le choix c'est ton
destin
je crois pas tu te réclames aller
consulter voir un médecin
si à chaque fois que vous entendez du
tambour vous prenez pour un loup il ya
quand même un petit problème vous croyez
pas
istanbul qui m'appelait peut-être qu'ils
ont raison les schémas que j'ai accès à
un autre monde pourquoi pas
au lit pour faire avancer la science ça
dérange qui moi ça me dérange
tes pouvoirs grande
[Musique]
tu en train de devenir coup les
compteurs et tu te rends même pas compte
je sais juste d'aller mieux louise
puisque j'ai merde
tantôt naguère votre grand mère
[Musique]
juste avant de mourir à ses furets qu'on
sera fermée
[Musique]
tous